[Applause]
how did you figure it out you know what
it was they were just too perfect the
pictures you know he was always looking
perfectly like like a great guy where
people were like this is really all just
a coincidence is it's just an accident
or actually we getting played here and
it turned out the media was being played
et's Kevin Frazier getting the Daily
Mail's Piers Morgan's take on the papers
reporting that Megan Markel's father had
staged paparazzi photos ahead of the
Royal Wedding so mortifying for the
royal family enraging our thing for
Megan Markel and for her dad come on man
what are you doing like I say very
embarrassing for everybody involved the
one he'll be most angry Prince Harry
Prince Harry will be really feeling in
rage because he still believes his
mother died at the hands of the
paparazzi that they chased her and
hunted her to her death the idea that
the father of his own bride-to-be is
colluding with the paparazzi that he
hates and potentially making money out
of this wedding will appalled and anger
Harry beyond belief
Thomas Markel has since apologised for
the scandal and now TMZ is reporting he
will not attend the royal wedding but
not because of the paparazzi pictures
instead it's reportedly for health
reasons the site reports he had a heart
attack just days ago ET spoke with Piers
before that revelation was made he's
gone from being the most famous father
of the bride in the world to potentially
the worst father of the bride we've ever
seen let's be brutally honest
you